let's talk about the war in Ukraine
because there's been a big shift
you've got Russia claiming to have
annexed four regions in Ukraine
some impressive games by the Ukrainian
Army
we understand that they are firing at
Russian positions about three kilometers
from here the tanks operating here are
part of a wider counter-offensive in the
East that has seen great success in
recent weeks
and then there's what's been going on
inside Russia
[Music]
what's up
plus the
whole issue of nuclear weapons but let's
start with the annexations President
Vladimir Putin has declared that these
four regions in eastern Ukraine now
belong to Russia how did that happen
will pro-russian officials in those
regions organize referendums and told
people they had to vote on whether they
wanted to join Russia when the results
were announced they appeared to show
that an overwhelming number had voted
yes but no one was surprised Ukraine and
his Western allies say the whole thing
was staged and illegal under
international law say foreign
an absolute sham we have multiple
accounts of people with guns Russian
soldiers or local pro-russian militia
going door to door and forcing those who
didn't flee to vote
[Music]
Putin went ahead and put on a Big Show
in Moscow to formalize it all
[Music]
this is him with the four pro-russian
leaders of those Ukrainian regions
[Music]
but the thing is Russia doesn't have
full military control over those regions
actually it's been losing ground fast
Ukrainian forces have made major gains
in the last few weeks the Kremlin Now
controls less of those regions than it
did when the votes were held the
ukrainians as you say are on a roll and
they think that they are pretty much
Unstoppable at the moment it's what
people mean when they talk about
Ukraine's counter-offensive they
essentially tricked the Russians into
thinking they were focusing on the South
but instead they attacked in the
Northeast so Ukraine's counter-offensive
is definitely a turning point this heavy
equipment that the the West has sent
that the Washington and the British
government in particular have sent has
been a game changer and there's been an
element of surprise that's benefited
them as well this kind of offense was
extremely important it raised Ukrainian
morale it showed that Western Arms are
working that ukrainians know how to use
them and that Ukraine is actually able
to win this war so there's a real sense
right now that military momentum is on
the Ukrainian side and they're still
pushing
[Music]
so here's where we need to look at
what's going on in Russia and President
Putin's response to all this he
announced a partial mobilization that
basically means the government calling
up more men to join the war in Ukraine
another 300 000 of them
but it didn't exactly pan out that way
and when the draft orders were sent out
there were all sorts of issues including
men without military experience being
told to go and fight
protests sprang up across the country
flights out of Russia were all booked up
and long lines started to form at the
international border crossings one
estimate suggests 260 000 men have left
Russia to avoid being sent to war
and yeah
regime
even some commentators on state TV who
are usually very supportive of pugu have
been openly critical of how the
mobilization is being handled and how
the war has been going because
so what could this mean for Putin well
it's hard to say but we do need to be
careful not to overstate the level of
criticism inside Russia anti-oh products
are very low
all in all in two weeks there were
something like four four and a half
thousand people only
that took part in auntie warrellis and
at the same time nearly two and a half
thousand of them were arrested what we
see much more is what we call Kitchen
products so beautiful sitting on the
kitchen and discussing between
themselves
our blood situation is look regime
stability comes down to who has the guns
and Putin and his guys still have the
guns he controls the security apparatus
and he's not gonna let that go but the
fact that more Russians are asking more
questions and people on state TV are
arguing the Russian military needs to do
better well that is a shift and it only
adds to the pressure on Putin in the
beginning absolute majority of our
population were thinking that this war
will last two three weeks the country of
psychologically was not prepared for a
long War
and this is the key factor now because
people don't understand why why they are
no Victory why there is no Russian flag
over here now hanging over all of this
is the huge question of nuclear weapons
and whether President Putin might use
them since the beginning of the war he's
been hinting that the option is on the
table and he did it again when he signed
off on the annexation of those four
Ukrainian regions
and those annexations have really ramped
things up because from Putin's point of
view any attack there is now considered
an attack on Russian territory and
according to the Russian law and to
according to Russian you create a print
attack on Russian territory should be
with a heavy Strike Back In other words
it could be met with a nuclear strike at
least in theory and in that scenario
most experts think we'd be talking about
a tactical nuclear weapon and more
likely the lower end of the explosive
range for those weapons to give you an
idea it could be similar to what we saw
in the 2020 Beirut blast only with
radiation but for the West this is the
ultimate Red Line we have communicated
directly privately at very high levels
to the Kremlin that any use of nuclear
weapons will be met with catastrophic
consequences for Russia that the United
States and our allies will respond
decisively and we have been clear and
specific about what that will entail we
are conveying the clear message that
this will have severe consequences for
Russia and that the nuclear war must
never be fought so would Putin even go
there I think he's going to face so much
discontent at home that he's going to be
he's going to force himself in a corner
and he's going to become increasingly
erratic and emotional which we're seeing
already and he's going to seriously
consider using a nuclear weapon I think
that's where we're going I cannot
exclude Congress that kind of situation
when
um nuclear tactic only tactical of
course developments can be used because
if for victory that kind of Step will
believe that it might have the problem
for cooking that he needs only military
or Ukraine defeat in this war will be
defeated not of all of him to be defeat
and the crash of the whole political
system so any kind of negotiated end to
this war seems completely out of the
question right now in fact we're
expecting things to step up before
winter sets in the weather temperatures
are getting quite cold and it's going to
slow down men in tanks and supply lines
so most analysts and people on the
ground say uh you know the next two
weeks are are quite crucial uh in in
terms of where things stand on the
battlefield we're Ukraine right now the
goal is to uh gain as much land as
possible till somewhere around
mid-november maybe late November and
then for the next three months is going
to be a war of attrition uh just troops
standing uh next to each other waiting
for combat to resume somewhere in late
March
in case you missed it check out our last
episode about the elections in Brazil
and don't forget to subscribe to Al
jazeera's YouTube channel so you don't
miss our next one see you next week
[Music]